je pense trois shows je pense que
laurent wauquiez est un homme de qualité
je l'observent en tant président de la
région rhône alpes où il fait du très
bon travail
j'observe qu'il est favori pareil que
selon toute vraisemblance il sera
président des républicains à la mi
décembre
j'observe enfin qu'il a un langage pour
l'instant pour séduire les militants
je trouve pour ma part souvent excessif
pas assez européen et donc pour toutes
ces raisons s'ils l'emportent
s'il venait à l'emporter il aura
sacrément intérêt à rassembler la
famille y compris des gens comme moi qui
sont des modérés qui vient de l'udf qui
viennent du centre du centre droit qui
sont profondément européen parce que
nous nous sentirions très mal à l'aise
dans un parti qui seraient trop
nationaliste trop conservateur sur les
valeurs sociétales et qui est serait
eurosceptiques ça veut dire que laurent
wauquiez président des républicains vous
ne quitterez pas immédiatement le parent
non non mais vous auriez de fortes
exigences on aura de fortes exigences
avec alain juppé nous sommes réunis à à
quelques-uns autour de lui au début à la
fin du mois d'août à bordeaux nous avons
indiqué nos lignes rouges ligne rouge
c'est celle là c'est pas sens commun qui
fait la politique des républicains
les républicains viennent de l'ump qui a
été conçu par le président chirac pour
être un parti pro-européen et enfin il
faut bonnet certes une politique
libérale mais elle doit être teinté de
politique sociale
donc nous avons indiqué aux lignes
rouges a indiqué clairement que si ces
lignes rouges vous n'êtes peut-être de
passer ce que je ne souhaite pas nous
serions amenés à réfléchir à faire autre
chose
d'accord c'est moi je fais partie de
ceux qui ont créé de l'ump avec jean
pierre raffarin régine et avec hervé
gaymard et quelques autres l'umpc tel
rassemblement des républicains libéraux
du parti républicain démocratie libérale
des radicaux des centristes cela ils
sont déjà partis à lui d y ait des
gaullistes sur des valeurs communes
donc moi je tiens beaucoup à ce que nous
gardions cet ensemble politique cohérent
mais il appartient à laurent wauquiez
s'il est élu de conserver l'héritage et
le brader